el mayor incendio forestal jamás
registrado en Nueva Escocia bajo este
espeso manto de un muy ceniza la ciudad
de barrington en la costa este de Canadá
se está asfixiando mientras los grandes
incendios forestales arrasan la
provincia el gobierno canadiense ha
enviado al ejército y ha pedido ayuda a
los bomberos estadounidenses según las
autoridades Es probable que los
incendios se iniciaran accidentalmente
por la actividad humana antes de
propagarse debido a las condiciones de
calor sequedad y viento hasta el jueves
por la noche unos 200 edificios habían
quedado destruidos 18.000 personas
habían sido evacuadas y decenas de miles
de hectáreas se convirtieron en humo
creo que es un momento estresante está
llevando un tiempo considerable hablé
con uno de nuestros bomberos y me dijo
que puede pisar una brasa y no se
apagará puede pisarla y retroceder y
vuelve a encenderse tienes que aplicar
agua es muy muy seco Mientras tanto al
oeste del país escenas similares como
helicópteros y bomberos luchan para
controlar las llamas bajo un cielo de
humo rojo la provincia de Alberta ha
declarado el de emergencia ya que los
incendios han arrasado sus bosques
durante más de un mes actualmente hay 61
incendios forestales en la zona de
protección forestal de Alberta 15 de los
cuales están fuera de control en lo que
va de año hemos respondido a 555
incendios que han quemado más de un
millón 120.000 hectáreas Canadá es
testigo de los incendios forestales más
frecuentes y graves a medida que se
acelera el cambio climático el país
tiene actualmente 200 incendios
forestales Ardiendo en siete de sus 10
provincias